our partners of the BBC report an  American missionary who traveled to a  remote island in India was apparently  killed by an endangered tribe that shot  him with arrows the body of 26 year old  John Allen Chow has not been recovered  it is illegal to have contact with the  tribe the president of the nonprofit  International Christian Concern said  this was at least the third time tchau  tried to meet with the tribe he was  determined to reach these people with  the gospel and was deeply burdened for  these guys it was a sacrificial act he  knew was dangerous  in a statement Cho's family said they  forgive those who are responsible for  his death